[vent qui souffle]
Qu'a t-il ? Qu'est-ce donc ?
Mais qu'a t-il prévu pour la dixième ouverture ce calendrier de l'Avent de YouTube de... Fabien Olicard du Mental Vlog,
de trucs plutôt cool parfois et des fois on ne sait pas ce que sait mais en tout cas c'est des trucs qu'il aime !
Eh bien bonjour à tous peuple d'Internet,
je vous ai prévu aujourd'hui... des énigmes !
Oui, parce que sur cette chaîne on aime les énigmes, mais bien souvent on aime pas quand ça nous prend trop la tête,
mais on n'aime pas quand c'est trop facile, c'est la difficulté du truc.
J'ai beaucoup aimé ceci, que l'on m'a offert.
La personne qui me l'a offert, sait que j'aime bien les énigmes, et du coup j'en connais beaucoup.
Et bien là, le format est assez sympa, ça s'appelle "Allumez les énigmes".
Oh ! Allumez les énigmes ! [imite Johnny Hallyday]
C'était Nicolas Sarkozy, qui imitait... Johnny Hallyday.
Dedans c'est fourni avec une boîte d'allumettes, ce sont des allumettes sécurisées, c'est-à-dire qui ne s'allumeront pas...
[rires] J'ai peur quand même tu sais...
Ça, c'est ce qu'on appelle une mémoire erronée.
J'ai peur que ça s'allume, et il n'y a pas de soufre.
Donc ça risque rien.
Et vous l'avez deviné, dedans, il y a comme son nom l'indique,
une cinquantaine d'énigmes à résoudre,
à l'aide d'allumettes.
Et bien je ne sais pas pour vous, mais moi j'en connais quelques unes,
avec des allumettes, toujours les mêmes qu'on connais depuis qu'on est tout petit, ou qu'on a appris au cours de notre vie.
Mais c'est la première fois que j'en vois autant et qu'elles me mettent à mal, alors,
les cartes ont un sens, d'un côté les énigmes, de l'autre côté la solution.
Donc il faut résister à la tentation de retourner trop trop vite la carte.
Il n'y a jamais d'embrouille spéciale.
Du style: la solution serait de casser les allumettes...
Il ne s'agit jamais de casser les allumettes,
il y a juste à chaque fois la logique à trouver,
ça peut être parfois des opérations mathématiques
style en chiffres romains, où il faut déplacer les allumettes pour recomposer la figure en chiffres romains.
Ça peut être des constructions de carrés, ça peut être des changements de formes, ça c'est par exemple
un poulet qui regarde d'un côté, et en bougeant seulement 2 allumettes, il faut qu'il regarde de l'autre côté.
Donc après il y a des fois des interprétations.
Là par exemple pour celle-ci j'ai bien galéré,
pour qu'il regarde vraiment de l'autre côté,
mais je pensais à une symétrie dans ma tête mais l'énoncé de dit pas qu'il faut que ce soit une symétrie.
Il faut juste qu'il regarde de l'autre côté.
C'est une piste.
Vous pouvez chercher.
Un indice en bas de votre écran...
Un bouton Like où tu peux appuyer...!
Ce n'est pas un indice mais c'est l'occasion de le faire ! [rires]
Voilà, je trouve ça très original. Ça ne sert à rien que je vous en parle trois heures...
Parce que sinon je vais vous dévoiler les énigmes qu'il y a à l'intérieur. Mais c'est cool.
J'ai un petit reproche à faire à ce jeu, parce que je suis quand même aller voir le prix sur Amazon
même si c'était un cadeau qu'on m'avait fait, pour voir le prix,
et j'ai vu que ça coutait 25€.
Je trouve ça un petit peu cher que ce soit 50 centimes d'euro l'énigme, mais si vous demandez ça en cadeau à quelqu'un,
peut être que... enfin j'en sais trop rien... voilà je vous dis le prix. Le jeu est vraiment cool,
je trouve ça un poil surcôté au niveau du tarif.
C'est tout.
Par contre, pour un budget moins cher,
j'ai trouvé un autre truc qui est assez drôle,
qui est à moins de 7€, c'est un calendrier d'énigmes.
C'est une bonne idée ou pas ?
Vous avez vu peut être, devant, près de mon canapé, dans certaines vidéos vous avez vu un calendrier de citations,
et d’explication, d'expressions.
Et bien là ce sera mon calendrier pour l'année prochaine.
Où chaque jour correspond à une énigme.
Et le lendemain on a le réponse de l'énigme de la veille.
C'est l'édition First qui fait ça.
Et t'as 365 énigmes pour moins de 7€. J'ai feuilleté un petit peu quand même parce que je n'ai pas pu m'en empêcher,
Il y en a qui sont assez simples, et il y en a que je connaissais pas du tout.
Une par exemple, compliquée, c'est celle du 28 mars:
elle s'appelle "Oublie moi".
l'énigme c'est: "31 octobre = 25 décembre".
Et la question: "A quelle époque de l'humanité cette égalité a t-elle était vérifiée ?"
Un indice: il est dans le titre.
[rires] Ce n'est pas aussi simple !
Je vais vous donner un indice, pour ceux qui aiment vraiment les nombres et les chiffres,
il y a un rapport avec l'octal et le décimal.
Bienvenue dans ma life !
Je pense que si vous appréciez de près ou de loin les énigmes,
mais plutôt comme un petit divertissement, une petite énigme à picorer de temps en temps,
je pense que ces trucs là peuvent vraiment vous plaire.
Puisqu'ils m'ont plu alors que j'en connais pas mal.
Comme d'habitude n'oubliez pas de laisser un pouce en l'air et de vous abonner si ce n'est pas encore fait.
Vous pouvez aussi me mettre des idées d'autres trucs d'énigmes dans les commentaires.
Et moi je vous dis demain, rendez-vous, mais vous remettrez dans l'autre sens... c'est maître Yoda qui a parlé.
Tchao !
[musique]